hey guys today it is the 20th of july my
name is just mcdonald and here's some
stuff that mattered in gaming today
capcom has unveiled a brand new
character who will be joining the other
brawlers of Street Fighter 5 the
completely original character named
McCauley debuted with an announcement
trailer shown before the street by his
for ultra finals during this year's
evolution championship series and he
looks pretty badass with an epic mane of
hair floating about him at all times
Macaulay has attacks which include a
ground pounding flashing and the
v-trigger move which transforms his hair
bright red for some reason confirmed
carica so far include Ryu Ken Chumley
kami birdie and n bison the games beta
will begin on July 23 at 6pm CT on ps4
if you're holding out for the real deal
street fighter 5 launches in March of
next year on ps4 and PC the good news is
the witcher 3 got that parts that
everybody was super excited about
unfortunately the bad news is that it
broke a bunch of things oh well digital
foundry broke down some of the issues
with patch 1.07 which include the
discovery that it negatively impacts the
frame rate on xbox one and ps4 in some
areas digital foundry explains
essentially game play on xbox one now
appears to rely on a similar double
buffer vsync set up to the ps4 game
locking its frame rate to 20 FPS during
these lulls in performance this means
that the reading on our graph is
consistently lower on patch 1.07 as
compared to one point 05 the ps4 is
suffering similar framerate stutters
even a long quiet countryside roads and
lower FPS readings than what the Xbox
one is outputting during cutscenes while
PC gamers are safe on the framerate
front there have been reports of
achievement to no longer functioning as
expected trouble aside the patch has
brought some welcome change
to the movement system horse behavior
and the inventory system among other bug
fixes if you like conspiracy theories
then you should be a fan of this one
there's been speculation that Metal Gear
Solid creator Hideo Kojima hinted at his
split from Konami through an existing
submission in ground zeroes a video
uploaded by time splitter 88 shows the
deja vu mission of Ground Zero where
players take control of the metal gear
solid one error solid snake and search
for flashbacks of the series's iconic
scene an optional objective in this
mission requires you to find and erase
the locos of Metal Gear games hidden
around the face any logos of games not
directed by Kojima are dismissed as
nothing special looks like that's
nothing special ominously at one point
it said might be able to erase the
markings but the memories will never
disappear this all hits pretty close to
home in light of recent events since
Konami just erased altered Erica Jean
reproductions branding off of metal gear
solid 5 the phantom pain box art let me
know if you think Azima planned this one
or if it was just coincidence you can
head to gain spot where we've got
stories on the new xbox one bundle and
talk over uncharted 2 resolution that's
it for me today let me know what
mattered to you and I'll catch e same
time tomorrow